[Music]
w
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begin
begins we are loud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels
hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them MAA wants a
Theocratic
monarchy that's right they want a
Theocratic monarchy the most unamerican
thing the most unamerican
idea that could possibly leak into our
public
discourse the in the
entirety of the reason why we have the
American experiment
anyways is because we did
not did not want a Theocratic monarchy
that's what we did not want we did not
want a dictator we did not want a
[__]
King no taxation without
representation manga has gone fullon
fascist they're with the now they're
saying Theocratic monarchy what they
mean is Theocratic
fascism that's what they mean and
they're using they're using the Bible
and their Jesus Republican Jesus oh
republican Jesus would totally want a
king Republican G it says King in the
book it says King it says it in there
Jesus must have must have got on his
knee pads and bowed down to a
king a king killed Jesus
dummy how in the how in the [__] don't
these people know that a monarchy killed
the
[__] hung him up on a goddamn
cross crucified him are they reading
this from the same book are they
actually not
Christians
H I'm an atheist and I know that much
Jesus
Christ really you don't know that [__]
they're ignoring it they don't care
about what is
real that's what the disease of fascism
brings that's what it
breathes it will continue to do that if
we don't do something about it like make
everyone know that that is what's going
on and bring it to Americans attention
that hey manga that manga thing how they
say they want to make America great
again that's all [__] they're lying
just like they're lying about being
Christian they're not actually that
thing they're bastardizing the entirety
of
it the whole thing thing front back
sideways up
down I'm not I'm not I'm going to
provide you the evidence today I'm going
to show you a clip today that should be
on the mainstream media over and over
and over and over again and all the
clips that I've been showing you that
right-wing watch has been putting out
for decades and decades and decades
folks this isn't new [__] this isn't
brand new
the difference is is the power structure
has now been taken over by the white
Christian nationalist Jesus Christ the
[__] speaker of the house over the
weekend was like oh that blood poisoning
thing I mean I like that idea and I
definitely want that idea I would just
use different words to say it like
German words I like the way Adolf said
it really kind
of Mike Johnson let me let me say very
clearly Mike Johnson is a [__]
Nazi Mike Johnson is a [__]
Nazi it's important that we make these
distinctions and I know there's people
on Fox News really mad really mad that
people like
me call them Nazis I don't give a [__]
listen if you're a if you're a white
person and you're a Republican or you're
manga and you're offended that I'm
calling people like you Nazis I'm
talking to you I'm talking to you
specifically if you're offended by the
words I say when Nazi leaves my mouth
I'm talking to
you it's very important that we make
these distinctions because they clear L
do not
understand words
mean but they definitely understand how
to slow roll we want Trump to be the
dictator I told you this is gonna happen
I [__] told you I [__] told you
and I hate saying I told you so I told
you so I told you so I told you so
because it's not that hard to see these
things it's really not that hard to see
these things coming and happening the
way that they're going to happen it's
not
hard I don't have a Chris to ball I mean
you can doubt me but I don't actually
have a crystal
ball we do not live in normal times this
is not normal and if you're thinking
about normal times like what is normal
and how it's going to happen because
it's normal you're way off the [__]
Mark that's the reason why the media is
Off the Mark and I hate MSNBC producers
listening to me right now because I know
you come here and listen you're way off
the [__] Mark your hosts are off the
mark your producers are off the mark you
people are way off the [__] Mark
you need to stop thinking in terms of
what is [__]
normal these are not normal times these
are not normal people in any normal time
in this country the media would go whoa
whoa whoa whoa some of the staunchest
supporters in the right-wing media are
saying that they want a Theocratic
monarchy and then they're like yeah but
it's unconstitutional to take Trump off
the
ballot like okay so you want the
Constitution or do you not they don't
they never wanted the
Constitution they've never wanted the
Constitution they've never been
Patriots they don't believe that black
and brown people should be here with
with us in this country As Americans
they don't believe immigrants that are
black and brown should come
here they don't want people outside of
their their their comfort of who someone
loves and doesn't love they don't want
someone outside their comfort
zone makes them feel all uncomfortable
when there's lgbtq people
around out in the open they don't want
that they don't want them they don't
want
them the others and there's always
another other right with
fascist that's actually how their entire
[__]
power structure collapses every single
[__] time every single [__]
time it's how it
collapses because they move from one
other to the other other to the next
other to the next other like today it's
lgbtq people and tomorrow it's
immigrants and then it's women's rights
and then it's the women's vote and then
it's anyone who's
liberal then it's anyone who voted for
anyone but Trump and then if you did
vote for Trump did you actually show
your loyalty did you really show your
and how did you show your
loyalty and and please prove it to me
before I kill
[Music]
[Applause]
you it's real
thing and it's it's here it's not it's
not coming it's
here
they're talking about using religion to
control you and your family and your
community Theocratic
monarchy it's going it's going to change
because they really mean Theocratic
fascism you know it's kind of funny it's
kind of funny because several months ago
um Theocratic fascist in
Gaza blew through the wall went into
Israel murdered and slaughtered a bunch
of Israeli citizen
cens murdered them committed war crimes
[__]
just disgusting [__] display of
terrorism and Hamas did it because
they're Theocratic
fascist okay period that's their [__]
ideology whether you like it or not or
you oh Tony genocide Joe Biden and BB
Netanyahu and all the [__]
arguments
Hamas are
Theocratic fascist okay Theocratic
fascist it is important to know that and
it's important to
know that it would be a
monarchy if they if they had someone to
be a
monarch manga in this country is Hamas
that's how it works that's why I said it
way back when it first happened that
manga is Hamas it's American
Hamas they're Theocratic
fascist they want to use their religion
which they don't actually believe in
they don't they're not actually
Christian they haven't actually opened
the book and read the gospel of what
Jesus would do you remember that [__]
when they when they used to wear
bracelets
these
conservatives you remember when they
used to thin mail their fascism oh my
God those were the days right when they
thin veiled it and like what would Jesus
do
wwjd everyone had those silicon
bracelets with wwjd on them oh man those
were the days those were the days in
America when they properly hid their
Theocratic fascism
what would Jesus do and really honestly
it's come full circle because you'd have
to ask these people who are like wait
wait wait wait you think Jesus you think
Jesus would be for a king to oppress
people that's what you
think and I know you thought I was going
to come on here today and talk about how
great the speech for Joe Biden was and
how demented the speech that Donald
Trump gave
we're going to get to
that but if I didn't point out this clip
and I'm going to play this [__]
over and over and over and over again
and there's going to be more coming
because once one of them is comfortable
saying it then another one's like oh
yeah we got to say that [__] too oh we
gotta say that [__]
too it just Cascades I see a lot of
people are worried about my hair this
morning I I I listen yesterday on the
Sunday rant we're back on Sunday rant um
Let me let me properly properly promo my
grift here the the way that my
microphone stays on is mainly the
patreon and if you if you contribute to
the patreon and you're a paid member you
get to come to the Sunday rant and last
night I came on the Sunday rant and I
didn't do my hair is kind of messy and
everyone's like hey it looks sexy so
this morning I decided to do it that way
intentionally so if you're liking the
hair it's it's because I'm I'm trying to
sex it up a bit you know what I mean I'm
trying to get attention so people you
know stay for two hours you know what I
mean I mean you got to look at this ugly
mug it might as well be a sexy haircut
right but a lot of people in the Discord
are posting a lot of memes and I just
want to point out that yes I I did my
hair for you this
morning I did my hair for you so if you
like the hair maybe go over and join
patreon it's free or consider being a
paid member to keep this microphone on
and then come join us on the Sunday
rants so you can hear me rant on Sunday
that's right every Sunday night well not
every single one of them but most Sunday
nights we're back on the train it's 2024
and we got [__] work to
do so I got to stay on them Sunday
rants like stink on [__] okay or stink
on
Trump oh boy so I called him Grandpa
Hitler you remember that when I started
calling him Grandpa Hitler after he was
like
dictator day one day one I'm gonna be a
dictator he wanted to be a dictator you
remember that [__] and I was like
Grandpa Hitler coin the phrase I was the
first one to it I called him Grandpa
Hitler over the weekend dementia
Hitler was trending how how there I mean
it's like they're always weeks behind me
it used to be months but now it's weeks
they just come directly to the source
they have much easier time you know what
I mean I know it's not the exact same
you're like Tony you're taking credit
for dementia Hitler well that's kind I'm
like yeah but I I was the first one to
say grandpa Hitler I was the first one
that morning the next [__] day to
call him Grandpa
Hitler and the main reason why is
because I called him Grandpa poopy pants
for years so I kind of did the Trump
smell thing too I called him Grandpa
poopy pants before diaper Don was even a
thing Grandpa poopy pants
because I always I always feel like
that's a really good name for him you
know what I
mean I mean the Cheeto dust the Cheeto
dust q and honor is good he used to be
the Cheeto dust mobster right because I
always figured he wanted to be a mobster
and he acts like a mobster he's a
horrible mobster by the way horrible at
it I mean Mobsters don't steal
classified documents and then record
themselves obstructing people coming and
get them they don't set up cameras in
the place that they [__] store this
the stolen classified documents and and
show the more crimes being committed
good Mobsters don't do
that they don't and and they're a lot
better at hiding millions and millions
of dollars of Chinese payments to you
and your family and your business while
you're president they do a lot better
job at that I mean what they do is like
Joe Biden and Hunter Biden did they buy
trucks and pay payments you know what I
mean truck payments that's how you hide
millions of dollar worth the
money least according to
Republicans but Grandpa poopy pants is
always fit him really well you know what
I mean it's it's the perfect it's the
perfect mockery of him because it it
aims at his age which they always want
to do that [__] Biden's too old he is
old Biden is old I don't know why what
what the [__] okay
so is Trump so if you're if you're
worried about his age maybe you should
be worried about the other the other
motherfucker's age too so Grandpa one
that fits you know what I mean
Grandpa and then poopy pants applies to
a lot of things not just that he shits
his diaper you know what I mean I mean
because that's kind of the you know the
direct mockery of it but it's also that
he's a [__] man baby because babies
are poopy pantes you know what I mean oh
you had a poopy in your pants you're all
mad and
upset so when he ever gets [__]
pissed off and you know he's [__]
turd raging I guess because he's got a
turd in his pants that's why that's why
I thought poopy pants fit great fit
great and these nicknames are important
right and I I know I know a lot of
people are like yeah but you're just
getting in the mud with him listen if
you're G to fight you gota you got to
get near him to fight it's how it works
I don't know if you ever been in a fight
but you don't fight someone from across
the street you got to cross the street
to fight them and you got to go on their
side of the street to fight them they're
not going to come over on your side
they're a bunch of [__] [__] ass
[__] have you ever met these Nick
boot Nazis have you ever seen these
people in person how they act when
someone challenges them have you ever
challenged a trump
supporter oh [__] they turn into poopy
pants immediately that's why it totally
defines them easily and him
so Grandpa poopy pants always fit him
very well right and it's still a great a
great nickname a great mockery of him
the Cheeto dust Q in honor also is is a
great mockery of him and I develop these
things
strategically it's all strategery you
know what I mean soul
strategery but it's all to weaponize it
the mockery um to form a message and to
make that message Cascade out right sto
purpose it's always the purpose for
commentary for narrative especially if
you have a driven purpose for it which
The Driven purpose here is for people to
engage in their
democracy and my message is always
always been against the Christof fascist
autocracies or the or the theoc fascism
whatever the [__] you want to pin it up
to be white Christian nationalism
there's all kinds of names for the same
[__]
thing same thing same threat been the
threat for a long time I've been
pointing it out the entire time the
entire
time I proved it last night on the
Sunday rant my very first political Tick
Tock and the reason why I'm here in
front of you today was about this very
issue
this very exact
one that's what it was
about I played it last night on the
Sunday
rant it's the one that went viral it's
went viral a couple different
times because it gets to the heart of
the
issue that these people fundamentally do
not understand that the reason why our
constitution was
written is because there was a
monarchy there was a Theocratic
monarchy and we as the American people
decided that we would go to
war against
it it was such a threat to our way of
life and our
Liberty and our life and our pursuit of
happiness
folks I'm telling you that this country
has a disease now the good news is is
that it hasn't metastized
yet but we have a [__] disease and it
ain't
Trump he is just the wart on our ass
that is the symptom of that [__]
disease and the only way out of it
because you can't you can't get rid of
an idea you can't get rid of an idea I
keep trying to preach
ideology right I keep trying to teach
people that there's not parties there's
only ideas the parties are the are are
the
institutional policy makers the
institutional organizations that set
policy in our two-p party system based
on our
constitution ideology is
everything all of it and until we learn
ideology we will not [__] get through
this
mess until we weren't learn what it is
and we learn how to properly put it in
its place we did it for years in this
country
easily we put ideologies in their place
after the second world war the
Democratic party basically looked at the
southern Democrats the ones that did
form the KKK the ones that were the
Confederates and they looked at the
southern Democrats and they said hey you
get to be bigots right you get to be
bigots if you want to be bigots you just
can't be bigots here
anymore they knew it was the death nail
to their party they knew it would bury
their party after the second world war
the Democrats had to come to Jesus here
even LBJ who was a total [__] racist
folks I'm not scared to say it that's
right LG L LBJ was a [__]
racist but he
knew he knew
that if he played into his Natural
Instincts and put his natural ideology
on display and set policy based on that
that that ideology that Natural Instinct
that he had he knew the party would be
dead he knew the country would be in
Peril LBJ was no was no
idiot he wasn't a
[__] he's a
racist
but he stood out of the way of civil
rights frankly he welcomed it in and
said hey we got to make this happen we
don't make this happen [__] shit's going
to get real
fast and it's kind of the Cross Road
we're at
now it's kind of the crossroad that
we're at now we have to get right with
these ideologies and understand that
Trump is not the overall threat he's a
symptom of the threat
he is just their [__] cult leader
that they want to hold up so they can
commit genocide on us whoever us is
whoever the others are in the moment
because right now there's others to them
tomorrow there will be different others
and once they get rid of those others
there will always be more others that's
what Theocratic fascists
do that's how fascism
operates it systematically gets rid of
the centers the
others and they demonize
groups to froth up the fervor to get rid
of others so that way when it happens
it's like well wasn't that big of a deal
they were they were [__] Vermin
anyways they were poisoning our
blood and by us ignoring ignoring the
actual
problem and trying to make it to where
Jack Smith saves us or chuin saves us or
the Supreme Court saves us or the
Colorado Supreme Court or the secretary
of state of Maine saves
us the more we look for these
Heroes who aren't actually have the
ability to save us by the way none of
those things have the ability to save us
or our democracy they're not going to
is that disappointing maybe I don't
think so I actually think that the power
of the Democracy should be in the hands
of the people that's the entire [__]
point no taxation without
representation We the
People life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness not the guarantee the pursuit
of
Happiness those are the foundations of
our
democracy
delivered by flawed men very flawed
men white men rich white
men did they dream that we would make it
to this point in our
progression of this constitutional
Democratic Republic I actually don't
believe
so but who gives a good godamn what they
thought what they
wanted the foundation of our
country is not for the Theocratic
monarchy or Theocratic
fascism you [__] [__]
eaters and the sooner we shake
loose the American Consciousness to to
show them this is what the [__] they
want and they're not going to stop until
they get it unless you stop them then
then and only then will the American
people gather up
together and a common
goal is to is to adhere to those those
founding
principles of We the
People of not having a Theocratic
monarchy the whole reason why the
American experiment
exist so that we can have future
Generations that see what a
constitutional Democratic Republic can
do and how it can
progress and how it invites all others
into the fold to be a Melting Pot of
success and one of the greatest [__]
countries to ever live on this round
Little
Rock that we all
inhabit that is the
foundation not some
King and anyone calling Trump a king or
even joking or a dictator or a dictor or
a Theocratic monarchy is 100%
fundamentally without
question
unamerican
unamerican and they should be called
that way that's why I'm going to call on
that every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube the books oface twitch and
Instagram here at the Tony Michaels
podcast for two full hours broadcasting
from the corporate headquarters of
antifa in Kami Falls Missouri don't go
anywhere I'm going to show these [__]
crazy ass clips when we come back right
after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thee Tony Michaels we're back
to the king of brill ions this is the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the show welcome
welcome welcome back thanks for joining
me every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours here on the tubes of
you the books of face the Twitchy
machine and the Grims the grams of
insta I don't know trying I'm trying
here everyone loves the haircut I think
I'm going to do it from now on like this
even that I might change it up every day
just to [__] with
you just to [__] with you I love all the
comments why not why not H Christopher
here is questioning pepperoni hug spot
yeah pepperoni hug spot baby Haven you
ever been to a pepperoni hug spot we
need to make more of those AI
commercials we really should we really
should do some of that this year have
fun with each other because it's gonna
be a hell of a year it's gonna be
[__] nuts really is it's gonna be
crazy it's gonna be knucking fots and
you're not going to want to miss a
single thing that's why you're going to
want to go to the Tony michaels.com
that's right go to the Tony michaels.com
hit subscribe at the top but here's what
I want you to do I want you to pan on
down now you can get your merch and that
sort of thing right here your your my
dog hates take Cruise merch or the
tattoo merch collection by the way I'm G
to get a tattoo really soon I'm gonna be
announcing something special this week
if you want to be a part of the tattoo
that's right if you want to be a part of
the tattoo I'm gonna be making a special
announcement this week um but if you
want to give support to the show you can
buy me a shot I love Jagermeister you
can get in the vinmo Super Chat I'll
bring your comment just tell me who you
are and what your comment is if you want
to get in the vinmo super chat or you
can just contribute to the swear jar if
you curse as much as I do but I want you
to go to patreon.com that is how we
support the show mainly that's where the
majority of the support comes from to
keep this show going um it is it is run
on you the viewer this microphone is
powered on against fascism by you now
you can join for free but if you are a
paid member you get to get involved in
other things
like the Sunday rant last night it's a
special rant it's a unlisted link uh you
can't see it or have it unless you are a
patreon member so go join the patreon
and also if you join the $20 tier uh you
can join us in the early mornings on
Monday and Friday uh in the producers
Corner as well and I also encourage you
to join the Discord if nothing else for
the book club both of those links are
here and do that another way to give
support to the show is on Twitch if you
have an Amazon Prime account you can
actually link your Amazon Prime account
to the twitch Twitch account and they
give me a couple dollars and it doesn't
cost you a single extra dime so if you
got a Prime account do me a favor link
it with your Amazon Prime account with
your Twitch account and get us that one
free subscription all the directions on
how to do it are right here at this link
right here all right the grift is
over you I I kind of I hate doing the
grift thing like I hate it you know what
I mean I'd much rather yell and scream
about Grandpa poopy pants or
how they're [__] Nazis and show you
the proof and evidence but I mean at
some point I gotta I gotta bring it up
you know what I mean because if you
don't bring it up everyone forgets they
just have fun listening to me yell and
scream so I I appreciate I appreciate uh
all this all the support you give rather
it's coming here every day and viewing
if you can't afford to be a member of
patreon or or do vinmo chats or buy
shots or anything like that those are
kind of like our super chats right I'm
not monetized on YouTube so I don't
actually get super chats they don't want
me to have it so we got to do it in a
roundabout way but [__] them [__] them
um so but again again I I want to
reiterate this microphone runs off you
and runs off your support and is powered
on against fascism because of you um so
uh Henry says it's okay to grift for
good cause Tony well and I I don't see
it as like grifting because that's not
what the show's about you know what I
mean like we're not I I run fake
commercials okay I mean I I'll run real
commercials if someone wanted to buy
them you know what I mean I mean we run
commercials over on Twitch I don't get
to control the commercials over on
Twitch but they run over on Twitch if
you're not a if you're not a paid member
or subscriber you see commercials which
that helps out the show too because I
get a little extra money for the for the
ads over there too but like you know
that's just that's just normal type
stuff but I'm not like Hawking boner
pills or you know trying to sell you
some [__] scammy ass land deed in
like some foreign country somewhere or
something or like a piece of the Moon
maybe I should do that maybe I should
just like start selling pieces of fake
planets just make them up [__] it you
know what I mean I mean if you're GNA
grift you might as well [__] grift
hard
so oh
boy sugar beat says rant grift rant
grift rant grift rant grift I mean I
could do that too right I like Randy
Randy rant rant grift gri gri grift
Randy Randy rant rant gri gri grift um
Reno renom mu on Twitch says Tony nfts
yeah I can I can make to Tony trading
cards you know what I mean we could we
could uh we could do we could do Tony
trading cards if you
wanted I don't know again A lot of
people are like well why can't you just
sit there and talk on a microphone for
two hours for free every day I mean it's
not exactly the way it works I mean it's
a it's a I gotta make a living somehow
like I gotta pay for [__] you know what
I mean I gotta eat gotta keep the power
on that sort of thing you know what I
mean you know what I mean so I
appreciate all the support that you guys
give no matter how how you give the
support whether it's to come here and
watch every day whether you're sharing
the links around social media um rather
you're going in chats and pissing off
people right or left about me I
appreciate all of that or if you are a
member of the patreon for free I
appreciate it I welcome you there and if
you're a paid member thank you as well
it is what keeps the lights on here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon e j 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full
hours two full hours
so uh let's see we want to go to some
clips but I was talking about um my Tick
Tock
and wna I want to show you ah God damn
it hang on a second I want
to um that really kicked off what you
see every day here uh I know you um you
might not give a [__] about this um but
I just wan to I just want to show you
that I've been saying this same [__] for
a long time that this threat because I'm
going to show you this
threat clearly I've been telling you
that they're going to start saying it
like this and here they are not but
weeks later there there's clips of them
saying it on weird ass podcast and it's
kind of cascade out right this is how
messaging works this is how narratives
work this is how Discord
works it it
Cascades right discourse works that way
messaging a narrative work that way
again it's kind of like throwing a rock
into a pond or even a tiny little Pebble
into a pond those ripples Cascade out
and and it Cascades here right so that's
the one reason why you start to see the
media start to say [__] that I say over
time because I'm The Benchmark I know
that kind of and it actually kind of
sucks to be quite honest with you it
kind of sucks that I'm the bench
I wish it wasn't that way um it'd be
much easier again to grift and make a
better living at doing this if I wasn't
The
Benchmark but it is what we have to do
in the [__] fam is what we have to do
for our democracy at this
point is we have to be the Benchmark we
have to pull them in a situation where
the message narrative is driven in a
certain way to where we can not only win
this election but win the down ballot
races and pile these sons of [__] and
fascist underneath mountains of [__]
votes it is it is vital to the message
that we send in this election at the
poll the only polls that matter which is
The Ballot Box it's very [__]
important more important than almost
anything else that we could have in
front of us in our democracy at this
point in this time and there's a lot of
issues to at hand to take care of like a
lot of them there's a lot of [__] we got
to do but we can't do any of that [__]
until we fend off Fascism and make it
get back under it's [__] rock and
it's going to take a little bit but we
will we will do it we will do it um and
this is the video again I look a little
different in it um sort of not really
but it's one of my walking rants now
this one is the black and white version
it was originally in color you know to
be fully transparent here um but if you
listen to the words in this walking rant
again this is the first political um
rant that I did on camera and post on
the internet okay I want you to remember
that I've been talking and ranting about
politics and arguing with people about
politics for for many decades um and and
the reason why is because I live in an
area where there's a bunch of [__]
eaters and always have been they've
always been [__] eaters it just Trump
didn't turn them into [__] eaters Trump
just turned them into the worst version
of themselves is all he allowed them to
do and give them permission that's why
they're like yeah Theocratic monarchy
that's what we want whoosh and they're
primed for it like they're biased to
having one person uh fix their problems
I mean that's what the whole thoughts
and prayers when when children get
gunned down in places like Perry
Iowa
yaldi uh uh in
Parkland and so many others this week uh
when children get gunned down they're
like thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers cuz one one [__] can fix
all that one you just ask one
[__] and he'll fix all of it
just like only I can fix it only I can
fix it remember that
[__] that's why he said it it's why
fascism is easy to get these white
Christian nationalist to believe and to
delude them into it especially when you
slow walk it a little bit you know what
I mean step by step by step well would
it be that bad that he was a dictator I
don't know it can't be that bad right I
mean I like the guy I'm supposed to like
supposed to like everything about him
and if I don't like anything about him
they'll probably kill me
so dictator it
is but I've seen this coming for a long
time now this video was originally made
in December of
2020 let me say that again the video I'm
about to show you is the very first
political rant that I
made and it kind of went viral several
different
times and I'm going to show it to you
and I want you to tell me if my message
every day for two hours every single day
the overall narrative the 50,000 foot
view of what we are trying to do in this
country has
changed since I did this rant in
December of 20120 take a listen so let's
talk about our democracy for a minute
reason why I'm so confident in the
fabric of our Republic is because the
fascists are concerned that it's rigged
against them here's a real big [__]
secret it is rigged against you you
[__] dummies the Constitution was not
set up or written to give your [__]
Christof fascist authoritarian [__]
oxygen you [__] Trump flag waving
Freedom [__] don't know what
Freedom Liberty or rights even are
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people it's not Liberty you [__] [__]
eating [__] and that's why it seems
like the Constitution is against you and
you're so [__] pissed off so let me
give you a nickels worth of free advice
either go get a history book on Fascism
and then participate in this democracy
or crawl back in your little snowflake
bubble where you belong it really is not
[__] rocket science Gomer pile [__]
them there you go I don't know you tell
me you tell me you tell me if my message
has [__]
changed you tell
me not a goddamn [__] bit of it has
driven away from my original message
from the very [__]
first very [__] [__] first political
rant I am in this
fight for our [__]
future and I know you're here gathered
up to hear that message and send that
message loudly and
proudly and I'm telling you we will save
our democracy with that
message
and that narrative alone just that
one and all we got to do is focus in on
it focus in on it get all the other
[__]
noise all the other noise out of our
ears and the more you focus the more you
concentrate the more you engage in that
messaging the more they'll have to
engage regardless of who it
is I don't care if it's the [__] eaters
themselves if it's the [__]
media if it's some that the people on
the left that they're messaging has lost
their way because for whatever reason
they gota have a great YouTube channel
and monetize it and sell this or sell
that and keep the advertisers happy or
keep the White House happy [__] them
[__] the Democratic [__] the Democratic
establishment [__] [__] the goddamn
campaigns [__] them [__] them
[__] them do not give in do not give in
this idea that we have to shill for
someone this is not our [__] Idol
against their Idol that is not what this
is that's not what that [__] video
said I didn't say a goddamn word about
Joe Biden Or democrats in that [__]
video not a [__] word not
one not one [__] word
that message that I put in that video
three [__] over three [__] years ago
and have been pounding the drum every
single [__] day
since the president of United States
stood in front of a microphone and said
that
[__] finally getting in front of the
microphone saying that
[__] the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not
Liberty you [__] eating
[__] you hear it every day when you
when you when you turn this show on you
hear it every [__] day that
phrase and that's where it came
from that's where it came
from that 60-second video that
idea and I could have stopped there oh
[__] I could have stopped there I could
have stopped that 60-second video oh
yeah [__] yeah could have stopped there
hell it went viral a couple times in a
couple different places and it probably
will go viral again and again and again
over the next you know five 10 six eight
years because the message never goes
away it doesn't fade past
that in this [__] crazy timeline that
we're
in and I'm not patting myself on the
back here I mean a little
bit what I'm trying to show you is what
we're trying to
do is we're trying to fight the
Theocratic
fascist the christto fascist
authoritarian [__] as I described it
in the
video the Nazis
and they're really really really really
really [__]
upset that they don't get just to get to
shred the Constitution and do whatever
the [__] they want however they want
when they want and no one can stand in
their way they'll [__] exterminate
them if they have to that's what
fascists
do this is the [__]
reality and I knew if we didn't get our
[__]
together that this [__] would start be
being said out loud that's why I say the
[__] I say out loud to get in front of
them you got to be in front of
them and there ain't no [__] place on
the internet there ain't no [__]
place in politics that is going to be
out in front of their messaging the
[__] people were trying to
fight to save the ideal of our democracy
to save the idea of Liberty here in our
country there ain't no [__] place
you're going to do it besides here
because I've committed the entire time
to that
message to that
narrative the entire [__] time every
[__] show go watch all of them and
tell me not one tell try to tell me that
one of my
shows that the overall theme in
messaging has not been that message hell
it's in the goddamn intro every [__]
weekday it's what gets me fired up about
doing this for two
hours and not because I want to be right
I do not want to be
correct I just am because because it's
the [__]
reality and let me show you what reality
looks
like here is
reality
listen to what MAA wants we're country
it's time for a Theocratic monarchy King
Trump for life let's go hey I think if
we had a monarchy there' be a lot less
corruption because you can't be bought
you know you don't have to be bought
because you're always in control you
don't have to be paid for with campaign
cash because you're always going to be
in control and you're going to pass it
on to your children and that kind of
thing especially if they do Bloodlines
but very interesting stuff just very
interesting stuff to do Bloodlines h i
wonder I wonder what it is about the
blood poisoning stuff that's clicking
with these people I wonder what it could
be they want a Theocratic monarchy now I
know you're like who is this [__]
winch who is this [__] [__] to I
know that I know that's what you're
thinking is it really significant that
she's saying it you goddamn [__]
right it is now this is this is a white
Christian nationalist Lauren witz or
witz whatever the [__] her name
is their message is cascading
that's the
point it has nothing to do with who's
saying it when they're saying
it the reason why Donald Trump can stand
up and say even suggest even just
[__]
murmur the words that he might want to
be a dictator even if just for a
day
is because they want him to
be they want him to be the
authoritarian Long Live King Richard
live King
Richard they want him to be the
furer get it
straight if they didn't want him to be
the dick
if they didn't want this unamerican idea
of a Theocratic monarchy and Theocratic
fascism if they didn't want that he
would have done been
done no one would be giving him money no
one would be talking about him he would
he would been in the trash bin of
History a long time
ago but we have a disease in our
country
and it is going to eat our democracy
alive if we don't [__] get rid of it
before it
metastasizes and you can't do a lot like
I mean I'm not talking about doing what
they want to do I'm talking about
getting them out of our [__]
government getting their hands off our
[__] policies get them to crawl back
underneath their dark shadowy
rocks where they have to hide these
ideas in the shadows because the
American people would [__] reject him
upon [__] hearing it and that really
is the
problem that is the
problem that we're not getting down
to the media the entire internet
apparatus every click every
view is about this motion and that
motion and oh oh Trump said this and
Trump did that and this court and oh
this the Supreme Court here and that
this there and oh they're going to make
this court date and blah blah BL yakety
[__]
schacky noise [__] noise and the
media buys it hook line Sinker and so
does Independent Media they buy it hook
line Sinker every [__] time
every [__] time it's the reason why I
have to be entirely untethered and be
totally independent because I have to
stick to that message from that video
that I first
made I cannot sacrifice the
messaging for no [__] sponsor for no
[__] for no corporate interest for no
[__] interest of clicks and Views
it's the reason why I spoke out against
Glenn and any of the 14th am Menders
it's the reason why I speak out against
anyone anyone anywhere Liz Cheney Paul
Ryan I don't give a
[__] if it doesn't [__] fall in that
messaging I don't [__] I ain't I ain't
going to [__] say the
[__] and I ain't going to say it just
[__] get popular on the [__]
internet either [__] that [__] I don't
care who bans me who [__] suspends me
I don't give a [__] if they won't
monetize me I don't give a [__] that
messaging is more important than any
[__] single nickel that anyone could
possibly rub together because this is
what we're fighting listen country
anymore it's time for a Theocratic
monarchy King Trump for life let's go
hey I think if we had a monarchy there'd
be a lot less corruption because you
can't be bought you know you don't have
to be bought because you're always in
control you don't have to be paid for
with campaign cash because you're always
GNA be in control and you're going to
pass it on to your children and that
kind of thing especially if they do
Bloodlines but very interesting stuff
just just a suggestion doesn't sound too
terrible it's worked uh throughout the
majority of history and uh King Jesus
remember our Lord believes in uh
Theocratic uh the monarchal
structure K
King off with his
head so you choose you choose who you're
listening to you choose what noise to
listen to now I know there's a lot of
noise with the news because there's a
lot of news I mean there was a guy over
the weekend uh in Tennessee who got
[__] naked and jumped into the fish
tank at the bass bro shot and boy what
video and what footage it is and how
laughable it
is Shaz were you in [__] Tennessee
over the weekend at a bass proo shop I'm
just wondering I don't know it seemed
like it I'm just saying it it's
similarities I'm just you know
similarities I'm just saying if you've
seen the video I'm not g to show the
video because YouTube will not want that
video and Facebook definitely H if you
want the [__] bass Row video just go
[__] just go to Twitter and type in
Bass Pro
Shop Bass Pro Shop you'll [__] you'll
see it or you won't see it you know what
I mean it's a guy it's a tubby guy and
he jumped into the [__] fish tank and
he ain't he's got a he's got a Eeny
weeny peenie he's got a microen he ain't
it you can't see his
dick they're always like ah there's two
genders and then you're like well what's
that what what is that
I mean obviously there's you know some
discrepancy somewhere I listen this guy
had such a small [__]
dick and I I'm not one walking around
with a huge slong right I'm not no
[__] Hunter Biden I I I you know I'm
honest with you I'm authentic I mean I I
would prove it but you know the internet
might not like that here's the point is
that I'm not hung like a hog like Hunter
okay but this guy makes me look like
[__] Hunter Biden the guy in the [__]
bass bro shop
pool right I I don't I Eeny weeny peeny
he's got a little
dick I don't one you
want but that was the big news over the
weekend big [__] news yeah internet's
like whoa this guy jumped in the naked
he ain't got a
dick just wondering if Shaz was in
Tennessee
anywhere H I don't
know I don't know but the inter internet
went crazy over this thing internet went
crazy over this thing just played
everywhere played on the [__] news
they were covering it that some guy
strip naked I don't know if he's drunk
or high I have no idea I don't know if
he's like on shrooms I don't
know I don't know if he wanted a swim
with the fishies I have no idea and
there were several other VI viral videos
made about the viral video you know what
I
mean f i don't
know guess how many times this video was
played on mainstream media this
weekend I bet you can
guess how many times you think this one
was
played how many times you think the
media showed these [__] [__] eaters
right here talking about how they want
Maga wants a Theocratic
monarchy how many
times I'll give you a guess it was a
hell of a lot less than the [__] Bass
Pro Edy beanie weeny teeny peeny
video you much more
important this [__] video is right
here to our society for the media to
show so much more important I mean I
like to watch the little dick video that
was great it was funny as [__] it's
[__]
hilarious it really is it's funny you
know it gives you good timeline break
like a cleanser from this type of [__]
the problem is that the media is not
talking about this type of
[__] oh they they talked about Trump's
uh Trump's he hay listen supreme court
February is it 8th or 9th I don't know I
don't give a [__] anymore I stopped
looking at these [__] dates to be
quite these Trump motions and these
Trump dates I stopped Jesus Christ I
don't I don't need the Trump crack okay
I just don't need the Trump
crack I got way too many other [__]
[__] eaters to try to pay attention
to that are talking about turning us
into a Theocratic monarchy by electing
Donald Trump and they weren't like
surmising this in the future in the past
they were talking about
Trump and this
election this [__] did not go
viral this video I just showed you did
not go
viral can you imagine if the majority of
Americans
heard what MAA actually
wants that they want a Archy they want a
Theocratic
dictator can you
imagine as the country as a whole
Saul and believe like they believe that
that guy didn't have a dick in the bass
bro shop pool or fish tank he thought it
was a pool maybe he was on vacation
maybe he thought he was at a [__]
water park I don't know have you ever
been to a bass proo shop they got like
the [__] museums and all the stuff to
animals and it's kind of wild in there
you know they they do a lot of [__]
show to sell you some T-shirts and some
guns you know what I mean that's really
what it is like t-shirts and guns I mean
they got other [__] in there
too I I I've been to the original bass
bro shop in Springfield Missouri and
I've been to the original bass proo shop
before basspro was Bass Pro like before
it was huge like when I was a kid we go
down there and go to the Bass Pro
Shop [__] Wild
how it's changed how big it's got and
that guy who owns it is a [__] [__]
eater
too but how much how much of a service
would it have been that America got to
watch this video as opposed to the guy
jumping in the fish tank it's time for a
Theocratic monarchy King Trump for life
let's go hey I think if we had a
monarchy there'd be a lot less
corruption because you can't be bought
you know you don't have to be bought
because you're always in control you
don't have to be paid for with campaign
cash because you're always going to be
in control and you're going to pass it
on to your children and that kind of
thing especially if they do Bloodlines
but very interesting stuff just just a
suggestion does I gu a suggestion you
know taxation without
representation the ocratic
monarchy now we got a
choice we can either ignore this and act
like oh she's just a dummy she's just
talking into a
microphone no big
deal no biggie it's not like there's I
don't know a speaker of the house that's
going to be questioned on things like I
don't
know
the Nazi the Nazi principle of blood
poisoning it's not like he'll be asked
about that and he'll say yeah I agree
with that it's not like that'll actually
happen like there's an elected official
who's third in line to the presidency or
anything it's not like that oh wait oh
wait when President Trump says
immigrants are poisoning the blood of
our country is that a statement you
agree with that that's not language I
would use but but understand the urgency
of President Trump's admonition he's
been saying this oh that's not the L he
would use he would probably say it in
German and get so excited that his arm
would get a [__]
boner and you go ahead and play
it actually you know what hang on to
that uh Rat hang on to that for a second
um can you play that again can you play
that
again
I mean you know he'd rather say in
German you know what I
mean you ra say in
German cut that [__] and put it on
[__]
YouTube I'm about right there
right it's pretty [__] good
huh it's what it sounds like when these
[__] are talking like that [__]
CU he's like oh I wouldn't say that so
many words listen to him listen listen
to this [__] fascist piece of [__]
listen to him again
listen blood poisoning right let's hear
it again from from let's let's hear
let's hear the English translation is
that a statement you agree with that
that's not language I would use but but
understand the urgency of President
Trump's admonition he's been saying this
since he ran for president the first
time that we have to secure the border
and I think the vast majority of the
American people understand the necessity
of that and I think okay so I if I'm to
understand this the whole point of
saying that you're G to poison our blood
all right this this is this is the the
point he's trying to make here he's
trying to put his pointy finger on it
his pointy hand finger on it right he's
trying to say that securing our border
somehow make sure that our blood isn't
being poisoned what what does that mean
does I mean there's only one true
definition of blood poisoning and it's
like a medical condition you know what I
mean it has nothing to do with brown
people coming in this country and
intentionally [__] white people so
that way that that it's less
white that's literally what they're
talking
about it's what they're saying they're
saying they're going to take your
communities they're going to [__] your
daughters they're going to turn them
black they're going to turn them Brown
that's that's what they're
saying and we need to secure the border
to keep the brown people out because
they're always talking about the brown
men you know what I mean they're like oh
yeah the men have you seen the men the
young men coming across and they're
going to poison our blood because you
know these white [__] fragile male
incels couldn't pick up a [__] woman
if they tried their
hardest keep listening keep listening
the the the the the [__] Monarch Lady
it's leaking out to this white Christian
nationalist think they agree with his
position but that statement goes beyond
what you are personally comfortable with
it's it's not language I would use but
but I understand um does it sounds
hateful well it's it's not hateful what
oh well it's not ha it's not ha easy
easy easy easy it's not hateful it's not
hateful now this is in the context of
the Republican the House Republicans and
the Senate Republicans staging a huge
[__] photo op down at the borderers
so they can talk about blood poisoning
because that's the whole point of the
[__] border talk right that's the
whole point of the Border talk and I'm
gonna piss some people off here in just
a minute so hang on to your hats I'm
gonna piss you off especially all you
mightest mighty out there I'm gonna piss
you off really quick oh it's
gonna Tony you can't say that the [__] I
can't the [__] I will now they're going
down to the border to create the blood
poisoning
narrative that's the whole point the
whole point of why they talk about
immigration why they talk about the
Border why they staged these stupid
[__] photo ops and they went down
there they staged the photo op and there
weren't there weren't any there weren't
any migrants coming across the border
when they were down
there there weren't there weren't any
because it's all it's all nonsense it's
all
[__]
those migrants aren't coming here to
poison the blood of our
country a lot of them are coming here as
refugees what how do you think America
was made how do you think our economy
was built how do you think our society
the fabric our society is so deep and so
thick with culture
huh you think white people did
that white people ain't got [__]
culture you kidding me [__] [__] here
bunch of [__] square dancing
[__] you kidding me you call
that
culture okay yeah good all
right those people are [__]
refugees those PE a lot of those people
come here to
work they bring their kids here to
become
American you [__]
[__] you [__] [__] and
anyone out there anyway including the
editorinchief Ron over at Midas Touch
talking about how the Border needs to be
the number one issue that people are
talking about if they're saying that to
you listen to me listen listen listen to
me very clearly listen to me very
[__] clearly if anyone I don't give a
[__] if they are a a a Republican or
they used to be a disantis republican I
don't give a [__] I don't care if
they're saying that the Border needs to
be the number one narrative and issue
they're a [__]
idiot you're listening to a godamn dum
dum is what you're
doing one who used to work for Des
santis you're playing into their [__]
hands when you do that stupid [__] they
want the narrative to be about the
Border because they want to scare
Americans that brown people are going to
come and [__] their daughters and take
their jobs and po poison their
blood so go on MSNBC and spout your
stupid ass [__] about the narrative
about the Border listen if America was
GNA vote based on the [__] border now
I'm talking about America as a whole not
the sh not the [__] eaters that [__]
think that this guy is some kind of
[__]
savior I'm talking about average
Americans who work with immigrants who'
been around [__] people who have come
here as refugees who have [__]
friends who are dreamers you pieces of
[__]
trash these are people who are more
American than this
[__] who are more American than
the people who say they want a a [__]
Theocratic monarchy which is
fundamentally 100% unquestionably
unamerican and if Midas Touch has Ron on
MSNBC or he tweets one more time about
how the border is going to be a big
[__] Pro a big issue in our election
they look dumber and dumber and dumber
and
dumber if it was such a big [__]
issue then KY Lake would be the [__]
governor of
Arizona
Carrie Lake would be the [__]
governor of Arizona because that was her
issue they're coming here and they're
stealing they're killing you they're
beheading people at the border we need
to build a wall and a fence and we need
to kill them as they come across that's
what the [__] she was saying and she
lost because even people in the border
state of Arizona knew she was full of
[__]
knew she was full of
[__] and it's disappointing it really is
disappointing that my buddies my friends
over at Midas Touch put that son of a
[__] as editor and Chief and have
Michael Cohen on their [__] Channel
after he's lied about the [__] AI
over and over and over again it really
is disappointing and I'm not scared to
say
it and I hope I hope they get a hold of
this and I hope they call me I hope they
contact me so I can express my
disappointment to them directly
but I am not going to sit back and let
[__] [__] eaters like this guy talk
about [__] blood poisoning using his
white Christian nationalism to try to
push a [__] message that brown and
black people and anyone who wants to
come here to [__] be welcomed into
our
society as an equal as Equitable in our
[__] in our
communities and they think that somehow
the [__] border is somehow the one
message and the one [__] thing that's
gonna sway the election you got your
[__] head on crooked you need to
pluck it out of your ass and you need to
get it [__]
checked you need to get it [__]
checked Kim P said I should contact Ben
oh I mean it ain't G to do no
good the only thing that'll do good is
[__] like this
if I say it in private it's in
private if I say it out
loud now now you got a
handle so what are you gonna
do and I told you it's going to piss
somebody off and and you know what maybe
all the people who got pissed off at me
a long time ago [__] left they'll be
back you know why they'll be back
because I'm going to be correct about
the February 9th SEC uh of Colorado case
it's going to go in Trump's favor the
president's immunity he's not going to
get presidential immunity the the March
4th trial date it's not going to happen
on March 4th I'm going to be right about
all that stuff because I don't give a
[__] about what feels good I don't give
a [__] about what feels good I don't
give a [__] about what feels good I give
a [__] about what's real and what is
reality and these [__] want to
switch the message to the Border they
want to have the discussion about blood
poisoning in this country because
they're Nazis
they're
Nazis it's not [__] complicated to
understand this [__] they want a
Theocratic monarchy and they want a
dictator they want a king and they want
someone who is going to exterminate what
they view as their
enemies and we cannot sacrifice any
wasted breath not one from now until
2024 because it's not about Trump I keep
saying that it's not about him everyone
wants to make the [__] about
him he's just their [__] leader he's
just the cult personality he's the idol
the disease runs much deeper than
him and we the people are the only ones
that can save
ourselves and the way we do that
is to absolutely expose these
[__] for what they
are expose them for what they
are and what they are is Theocratic
fascist oh still don't believe me
huh I mean I got more clips I got more
Clips to show you hang on hang on here
we
go here we go here it is it said in uh
Ezekiel
23:30 said God looked for a man to stand
in the Gap but none was found God found
one in Donald J
Trump he's standing in that gap for us
right
now so
this is I've never I haven't been in the
front of this many people
before and I I come from a very small
town who doesn't we don't have many in
our
church he's very nervous about spreading
his Theocratic fascist message in front
of a lot of
people very [__] nervous especially
at a trump Nazi
rally folks this [__] is real
I keep telling you I keep showing you is
real and narrative is real and I know
you're hearing me and you're you're
you're out there spreading the message
that's a whole
point but I got to do it with some
some some conviction I got to do it with
some fire
because no one else
will they'll get us
distracted right like o Ron here let me
point it out to you here's o Ron here he
says
wow Des santis finally taking the gloves
off releases a brutal attack ad on Trump
for his record on the border tonight oh
yeah Ron he sure did release an ad of
everyone but him saying
it any opportunity Ron gets to talk
about the
border and he tried to make it to where
Ronda santis takes his gloves off Ronda
santis does not talk in this video Ronda
santis does not say [__] in this video
not a [__] word does RONA Santa
say Ron is it watches rightwing media
all the time he's constantly watching
this [__] constantly keeping track of it
keeping tabs on it and the guy still
doesn't understand
it still doesn't understand it he
doesn't get
it doesn't get
it still didn't get it and maybe the
reason why Ron is so [__] brainwashed
by this border step is because that's
all he sees on right-wing media he can't
distinguish the difference between what
he keeps hearing on right-wing media and
what is
reality hell if Ron watched enough of
the the um the Theocratic monarchy stuff
[__] he might start believing he might
start
believing that there was there was a way
for for for Theocratic monarchy to live
in this country
I told him because I want Ron in this
fight okay I want you to be clear on
this too I want Ron in this fight and if
Ron ears this I want you in this [__]
fight I want you in the fight for
pro-democracy even though I'm still
skeptical whether you're Republican
still or not very skeptical I'm very
suspicious Ron very suspicious
even though I every time I show one of
your videos every time I've always
thanked you and gave you credit because
I know that's what Ron want Ron always
wants the credit he always wants the
credit for stealing someone else's
content putting it on
his but Ron I want you in this
fight I know you think it's important
narrative in this cycle but you're just
grasping at stolls and I'm talking about
the Border this is a flimsy attack
against Republic Republican Jesus that
has already been tried it failed then
it'll fail now by the way why do you
continue to talk about the border cycle
the last three or the continue talking
about the border the last three Cycles
he's been talking about it it's the
number one issue it's GNA drive people
to the polls it's GNA be the reason why
people vote against Democrats is because
of the
Border he's
wrong he's he's he's
wrong it's Theocratic fascism
that's what will drive people to the
polls it's the idea that we need to have
a Theocratic monarchy and and Donald
Trump is gonna take away women's rights
to Health Care like he did by destroying
roie
Wade they're going to ban women's
privacy in doctor's offices they're
going to take away the right for people
and the liberty for people to love who
they want to love they're going to take
away your ability to make a decent
[__] wage in this country
they're going to take away your ability
or the hope that you that you won't go
broke because of a medical bill I mean
unless you're rich and white then you
won't have a
problem who do you think decides all
this [__] in a Theocratic monarchy do
you think it's the people who decide
what kind of Health Care they have what
access they have to it do you think it's
the people to decide what constitutional
measures are in their state
constitutions do you think it's the
people who decide how their children are
educated at the local school board by
voting school board members in do you
think that's how a Theocratic monarchy
Works do you think a Theocratic monarchy
has a decent border policy so that way
we can M make sure to welcome plenty of
migrants into this country so we have
plenty of Labor so that way as our
economy grows our economy can get bigger
and bigger and stronger and stronger
because of those migrant
workers because those people doing the
work that [__] privileged ass white
lazy people don't want to do huh what do
you think Ron what do you think what do
you think they're [__] dumb [__]
huh I'm not going to stop calling it out
and I'm not going to stop [__]
pointing at these people until they get
on the [__] side of
reality and what reality is and it's
coming folks it is [__]
coming honestly it's already here I'm
going to
come
it's already
here and yeah we got to mock them we got
to continue to mock them we got to keep
doing
it look at this here here's here's a
here's a rep out of Tennessee his name's
Gino B bolso Gino
BSO listen to what he says about what
values he wants people in America to
live live go ahead let's hear G know
what does an LGBT flag indoctrinate a
child
into well I guess it really depends I
mean it's it covers a very wide swath
which is really where the problem is uh
certainly you're familiar with the
Supreme Court's decision in 2015 in the
overell case that effectively flattened
any state laws that supported
traditional marriage and held that the
equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment uh requires that all states
put uh same-sex marriage and
heterosexual marriage on exactly the
same footing that's one issue that I
think that Flag
represents alsoo said he thinks the
values children should be taught are
from the
1700s 50 years ago we had a consensus on
what marriage is we don't have that
anymore a 100 years ago we had a
consensus on sexual morality I don't
think we have that anymore so um the
values that I think most parents want
their children exposed to are the ones
that are are the ones
that were in existence at the time that
our country was founded oh yeah
1776 Baby W
yeah and you and you think I'm crazy
when I'm like they're not they're going
to try to get women not to vote they're
going to try to strip away women's right
to vote they're going to strip away
women's right to even ex exist
independently they're going to be
property again
1776 we we we've lost we've lost what
marriages no no no no no no no no no we
didn't lose it you lost it you lost what
you think what you think and you have
the Liberty to think whatever you want
whatever boneheaded idea you want Gino
you got whatever [__] bigot spigot
that you're drinking from and any idea
that you want to have
that's up to you my
friend but you do not get to tell
us what to do you do not that's right
they don't Jim points out no interracial
marriage they don't want interracial Mar
they they listen
17 tick your clock back to
1776 and imagine in Birmingham Alabama a
black person driving down the street in
a car cuz in 177 six in Birmingham
Alabama black person would not be riding
on a [__]
horse that's the values that Gino here
wants oh yeah we want to get back to
those values in our society they're not
talking about founding principles of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness We the People right taxation
without representation they're not
talking about those founding principles
that's not what he's talking about he's
talking about he's talking about the
values in your [__] bedroom in your
pants in your mind in your church in
your community they want to strip away
all your individual liberty away from
you because when you have your
individual
liberty they don't get to have their way
they don't get to tell you what to
do they don't get to tell you who you
can and can't
[__] who you can and can't love what you
can dress like oh my God what a travesty
that everyone's not running around in
white robes and pointy white
hoods [__] out of here with this
nonsense and you think I'm
crazy people think I'm crazy to be to be
[__] making sure that I'm putting
people in their place when they're
losing their way on their messaging
because they want clicks and they want
attention I could do a lot of [__] for
attention oh my God [__] [__] I can I
can sing I could dance I can do the show
I could be I could be the the [__]
clown I could go record a Tik Tock video
every two and a half minutes to say
something dumb that doesn't have
anything to do with anything I could do
that all day long [__] I can do
that that ain't what will
work I believe in
this you believe in
it and they hate it this [__]
hates it oh my God can you imagine if
this [__] [__] eater watched just two
minutes of this show he lose his [__]
mind like oh my God Tony Tony is the
spawn of
Satan yes I am yes I am loudly and
proudly [__] sheet eater I cannot
even believe that we are in 2023 and we
got to watch elected state
representatives say [__] like
that
but we do one of the reasons why is
because we got to watch this kind of
[__] people who are loud and proud about
being [__]
[Music]
traitors yeah yeah [__] [__]
anti-fascism what is that what does that
mean what the what could that possibly
mean so antifa means anti-fascist right
okay let me antifa means anti-fascist
now these are the proud boys if you
don't know and they were celebrating
January 6 because they were proud that
their leaders are a bunch of [__]
traitors and they're all and they're all
in [__] prison because they're
traitors okay that's what this is that
the the the tens of proud boys that are
still
left [__] antifa think about it think
about it
if
anti-fascists don't like fascism and
their name is antifa
right and and and proud
boys are yelling and
screaming [__] antifa what what does
that mean does that mean that they want
fascist because it feels like to me it
really does feel like to me that these
[__] traitors want fascism or I don't
know you could call it a Theocratic
[Applause]
monarchy [__] boy never forget Ashley
babit never forget Ashley babit oh
[__] you know what over the weekend I T
I took shots like Ashley babbett did
pounding those shots bow bow bow bow on
January
6 tastes so
good what a bunch of [__] never
forget oh we're not gonna forget we're
not gonna forget that Ashley babbit is
somehow your Idol because she's a
[__] on [__] q and on crazy
[Music]
shitthead Trump told her to go do that
okay all right yeah we won't forget
her by the way the other thing too I
want to point out when they zoom in on
this check out these these
guys oh my God this is the master race
here this is supposed to be the master
race this is what they're convincing us
of that is going to win the day of ideas
in our country they're gonna win the day
right okay yeah
[Music]
right say her
namey
say your name you won't even show your
face you won't even show your
face yeah you're just waiting them for
the give the Nazi the Nazi salute I want
to show you another video of them though
a more
proper I want to give you
uh another another proper video of him
my buddy good trouble over on Tik Tok
well I think he's mainly on Instagram
now we actually had to pull this video
from Instagram but he put it on Tik Tok
also but uh this is good trouble
properly mocking them uh I I put it on
the I put it on I put it on Twitter this
morning so you can watch it there but
let's take a look at
it
Fu So Yesterday a bunch of adult virgins
took to the street to have like a to
celebrate January 6 because of course
we'd [__] do that uh but I just have
a few little tasty morsels for you this
guy
stay the [__] over here I I'll tell you
again stay out here don't [__] come in
here we're gonna [__] you up the
bulletproof vests scarf combo is a
choice for sure uh slay Queen I guess
they're
serving [__] you live by tonight is it
in hopes that this guy would buy you a
bulletproof vest that fits
crop top
bulletproof hot do you know your [__]
history do you know what this
means zero quarters given zero quarters
given exact change only have that's not
the correct phrase but and also the
irony of this mouthbreather yelling at
an anti-fascist about learning their
history as if America has not fought two
[__] world wars about this Kim make
that [__] up [__] you
upil want [__] Isis plate
[__]
on the concept that these people have to
cover their face and are afraid to have
their license plates shown uh call
themselves The Proud boys is a ju a
position that has never not been funny
it's [__] Evergreen seems to me that
proud boys wouldn't mind showing their
face and and letting their employer know
that they belong to an organization
such as that as opposed to the intensely
insecure rattled threatening of someone
taking video of you getting into your
[__] Prius that is that a proud boy
does not make anyway here's hoping that
you Slither back into whatever basement
you guys crawled out of and [__]
never
return I couldn't said it any better so
I look good I look good trouble say it
and that's how you properly market and
that's what we have to keep doing that's
how you point it out that's how how you
show it because folks it's [__] it's
it it's here it's already here and it's
all around the world too uh my my buddy
Christopher Webb uh posted a video this
morning that was shown on Twitter now
this is in Rome
Italy okay this is Rome Italy and this
is 2023 this is Rome or 2024 EXC excuse
me Jesus Christ big step fan please zero
days on the um on the mark that I'm uh
don't know the year
yet I'm trying I'm [__] trying to get
the year right it's gonna take a couple
[__] weeks okay it's 2024 this is
2024 in Rome Italy take a listen see if
you can hear what I'm
[Music]
hearing
[Applause]
[Music]
for
now these [__]
cucks these fascist cucks were in
America they'd be wearing proud boy
uniforms that's right they' be
supporting make America great again
wanting a Theocratic
monarchy this is not this is not 1930s
Germany this is not 19 1940s Italy this
is
2024 Rome Italy take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
again
now you cannot believe me if you don't
want to that's fine I mean there's
plenty of people who come every day and
don't believe the [__] I
say believe me when I say this this is
coming to a trump rally near you
soon maybe not so orchestrated because
let's face it the Trump cult just isn't
quite as coordinated as these people in
Italy they're just
not but
it is coming to a trump rally to you
soon um let me properly mock them and
show you video that I
found it really looks like they're
practicing they're trying hard they're
practicing really hard at these rallies
to try to get this down here it is um
here is and and guess what Ron posted
this video so thank you Ron thank you
for the video see I I properly thank Ron
when I need to thank him but here's a
video that Ron stole um what do you want
from me Ron Ain got the cameras at the
rally he just stealing the footage and
posted on his Twitter account but you
see right here there's the my pel Nazi
and you can see all the white Christian
Nationals here look at look at look at
these guys look at these [__]
they're trying hard it's a video so
watch I mean look look look look at this
I you know listen you shouldn't be going
to to a rally especially a white
Christian nationalist rally and be doing
this type of hand motion okay just
really
shouldn't no no no no no no see these
people she's got her thumb up this lady
had her fist pumping look here she was
pumping her fist and this lady here's
pumping her fist they really it's not a
Josh Holly Nazi salute you know Josh
Holly he thought this he he didn't he
needs to you know they need to make
Hitler proud and really get their
fingers out there really straighten the
arm out that's all I'm saying you know
they're they're getting there though
they're really learning take a
[Music]
look this woman this guy right up front
look at this they got it down pat man
look at this look at that oh man they
[__] got it down now of course I'm
mocking them right and I I really
thought at first when I first seen this
video because I seen it in my feed
without the without the noise or the
sound proud being American where at
least I know I'm gonna vote for someone
who's going to take away all my [__]
rights and make sure that I'm oppressed
and all the people around me oppressed
and then and then I won't have any other
choice but to bow down to the dictator
the the Theocratic marchy least I know
I'm
free oh my God H the
irony the
irony but they almost got it when I seen
this uh clip when it didn't have any
sound I was like man they're really
they're they're really working it out I
want to also point out um you know their
big dictator and King and he's the he's
the greatest ever and he has these
biggest rallies and all these best
places I don't know if you're looking at
this [__] building but it's like a
hog
Barn okay this is like this is what we
build hog barns out
of livestock barns okay this is that
like a this the King King King [__]
Cheeto here is at the is at the county
the county fair Fairgrounds you know
what I mean he's at the county
fairgrounds right yeah it's a hog farm
ju Julie oh that's the wrong one
if you like to go to the small state
fair yeah that's what a county fair is
like a small state fair and Julie says
hog farm it is this is what this is what
we [__] these are buildings that we
build hog barns out of cattle barns out
of you know what I mean this is what a
goddamn tractor shed looks like okay
this is not the Trump Hotel this is not
the Trump
International you know bankrupt room 26
or some [__] okay and the reason why he
can't have it but anywhere but a goddamn
cattle field and right now he can't have
these [__] things in in in the
goddamn cattle Fields where he doesn't
have to pay anybody money because he
ain't got no [__] money and he ain't
got no credit no one will let him have
an event anywhere in a city and the
reason why is because they don't want
him there because he doesn't pay his
[__]
bills yeah Cynthia says it's a preab
metal building yeah exactly it is a
preab metal building thank you Cynthia
if you want to be more
technical in another life I used to sell
pre-fabricated metal buildings oh man in
another life I used I used to sell them
I'm dead
serious that was that was my job that
was my business is to build buildings
like
this and most of the buildings that I
built were
agricultural because most of them that
are this big are AG agricultural style
buildings you know what I
mean oh
boy oh boy yeah they are nice they're
nice they're nice especially if you
finish them out on the inside because
you can finish them out like you can
make a building look like a church like
this you can make it look like a church
you can make it look like a community
center a really schnazzy one too like a
like a hotel Event Center you know a lot
of these prefab buildings are built like
this or hotel event centers but this one
clearly is is is not finished and it's
not schnazzy right and and Trump wants
us to believe that he's high futin and
all high class and [__] right now again
this is Rule America
okay this is quintessential rule America
is what this is this is what I know like
I know this better than I know anything
else why do you think I know who they
are and what they're going to say and
how they're going to say
it I knew people would cut um
screenshots of me giving the Nazi salute
and post it all over the Internet why do
you think I did
it oh boy but here they
are praising their Jesus right praising
their Jesus all 200 300 of them he gets
the biggest crowds right they to they
have to rent all the biggest Arenas all
the biggest Arenas because he has the
biggest crowds and everyone loves him so
much it's only the feeble-minded and
only the few who love him so
much don't be scared of these [__]
don't be scared of their love to have a
a Theocratic
monarchy don't be scared of
it we just got to make sure we fight it
properly because we do not want it to
take hold
in this country all right let's move on
to some more Clips let's see um speaking
of Theocratic fascist what about Troy
nles and and Senator Mark Wayne Mullen I
hear they like Theocratic fascism Mark
way mu's always talking about God and
Jesus a he's like Jesus this God that
Hitler this Trump that you know what I
mean that's kind of like Mark Wayne
mullen's little thing and then Troy nles
speaking of the Border Oh Hey Ron
speaking of the Border Troy nles says
there's no way he's ever going to help
pass any bill that helps the Border
because then Joe Biden will get the
credit and this is republicanism 101
right this isn't
new representative Troy nles from uh the
Texas's 22 he's a United States
Congressman he's on the Jud uh judici
Judiciary Committee by the way and he's
part of the freedom caucus and he's part
of the transportation
Transportation committee now Troy nles
is saying he absolutely will not support
any bill that helps fix the border and
the reason why is because then Joe Biden
will get the credit they don't give a
[__] about the Border they don't care
about the Border Ron they don't care
about the truth Ron they don't give a
[__] about immigration Ron they only
care about their
power that's it period until you [__]
wrap your mind around that and realize
that that's the [__] reality you're
going to have situations where you're
going to be able to look at video like
this now if you're
unfamiliar this is in the house chamber
and this is one of the house doors to
get onto the house floor and the glass
here is broken and this little [__]
eater that you see through the little
window here that's Mr I don't want to to
pass immigration because it would help
Mr Joe Biden and it would help him get
reelected so I'm not going to do my
job so that way Joe B and this isn't new
okay that sentiment isn't new by the way
you remember a scumbag called Mitch
McConnell all the way back in 2009 this
is a long time ago folks 2009 2009
right he is number one goal his number
one goal Mitch McConnell's goal back
then was to make sure that Barack Obama
was not a two- turn president it wasn't
to work for the American people it
wasn't to make sure that the Senate
passed good legislation and set good
policy and change policy for the
American people for the better right
nope that was not their number one goal
number one goal is to make sure the
scary black dude with the funny name did
not become president again number one
goal it's also Troy n's goal goal here I
wonder what his goal was in this video
this is January 6 let's see how he felt
about MAA supporters and the people he's
trying to work up into a foamy froth
over the border to to to to advance the
blood poisoning narrative let's see what
Troy nles thought about those people
let's
listen are all
your how do you handle this open the
door brother how do you handle it come
on man open the door
social what's with you
fing gots we got kids
F can't hear leave leave and then this
this is marway M this is the tough guy
remember the tough guy that's like hey
that guy who wants to bring who wants to
bring the teamsters back to the Jimmy
hofa days I'll kick his ass I'll kick
his ass and then Bernie Sanders's like
sit down [__] and he's like okay I'll
sit down sorry Bernie sorry I'm really
sorry that's that guy that's that guy
right here right here
okay now if these were tourist like
these [__] eaters Troy nles and markway
Mullen want to convince us are they now
that they're just tourist why wouldn't
they open the door and welcome in and
show them a tour of the house floor huh
why why wouldn't they do that why
wouldn't they welcome these tourist in
they were just Trump's supporters there
to tour the capital right before they
stopped by the gift shop they stopped by
the house floor to get a tour with Troy
nles and Mark Wayne
Mullen now why in the hell didn't they
give them the tour that they so
deserved I wonder what the [__] it could
be I wonder if it was that they didn't
know they were tourists then they knew
they were terrorists then or I wonder if
it's Troy nles and Mark Wayne Mullen are
just [__] lying to us
now yeah that's another thing they're
pointing out in the Discord that Troy
nles has a [__] mask on what is he
some kind of
sheep look at him look at him what is he
some kind of [__] sheep huh you
believe in the planemic Troy is that
what you do huh
[__] they're lying to you it's
all lies it's all [__] and they use
white Christian nationalism to push it
every single time they they they're
going to push our country to the brink
they're going to [__] try to use our
democracy to destroy it with right
Christian nationalism they want a
Theocratic monarchy they will never
never stop wanting that these people
believe in this [__] garbage in this
[__] trash look at this [__]
listen we're your
friend why I don't think they're GNA gas
no we just got pushed up the front I've
never had a ticket in my life hold on
man ever never you want my
license we are real American citizens
who are sick of this and we're making it
knowing that we're sick of it okay years
would you huh never had
people 30 years Troy nles has been in
law enforcement for 30 years and he's
never had tourists act this way
huh kind of
funny kind of
funny 30 years Troy nles has been a law
enforcement he's never had MAA
tourist act this way
that's because tourists don't act that
way they're selling you a bunch of Lies
now because it doesn't fit their
narrative because we're on to them that
they're a bunch of [__] Nazis they
want a Theocratic monarchy they're
frothing and foaming at the mouth for
Fascism and Troy nles and Mark Wayne
Mullen and Trump and the rest of them
all of them Marjorie Taylor green Lauren
bobert Mitch McConnell Paul Ryan Liz
Cheney yes they were selling the bill of
goods to these people to increase the
chance that a Theocratic monarchy could
take hold and fascism could be the
[__] founding principle of this
country because folks that's what they
really want they want to win and they
want to wipe the history
away so [__] Troy nles and [__] I've
been in La for years a little louder
that's because you've never seen
corruption like we have seen this last
month
and I'm ashamed of he's ashamed Troy
nles isn't ashamed anymore that's
because it doesn't fit Troy n's
narrative
anymore doesn't fit his [__]
narrative anymore doesn't fit it
no I don't think
so in that moment their lives were at
risk in that moment their lives and
their safety was
threatened by those tourist I'm not
afraid of
biting and that's why Mark Wayne Mullen
and Troy nles were ashamed at that
moment because their lives were at
risk they don't give a [__] if our lives
are at risk you think they give a
[__] if our lives are at
risk you really think they give a
[__] when they come for
you I mean [__] they're saying it out
loud and they love this guy listen to
him begin the largest domestic
deportation operation in American
history we have no chance round them up
round them up oh well they're not
talking about round they're not talking
about rounding up the Troy nles of the
world so he didn't give a [__] ah he
doesn't care about that what would he
give a [__]
for ah he doesn't
care he doesn't care he doesn't care he
doesn't care if this is the
narrative I'm gonna be a dictator for
one day I'm gonna be a dictator for one
day H
Trump H
Trump Theo ratic monarchy and Trump is
the king Lord
Jesus you want
more I'll give you more here you go
here's more of
it president Trump calls the evil people
trying to destroy this nation and that's
exactly what it is I spoke a little bit
about that earlier there is an evil in
this country I'm not sure we've ever
seen
before we are a god-loving
country and our
faith is stronger than the evil that's
trying to destroy this
country but it's up to us the god-loving
people to make sure the devil who is
working
overtime does not keep destroying this
country
the messaging is everywhere the
Theocratic fascists are out and
about and they're
ready they're [__]
ready and they're going to use God in
God's name to [__] do
it the question
is are we going to stand in their way of
[__] like
this Grandpa Hitler posted this [__] on
his [__] true Social account it's a
video not made by him but made so he'll
post it on his true social it's called
God made Trump now at first glance this
[__] is laughable because anyone who's
read any of the Gospel at all or studied
the gospel at all or just heard stories
from the gospel at all know that this is
a bunch of trash and a bunch of [__]
but
[Music]
watch
and on June 14th 1946 God looked down on
his planned paradise and said I need a
caretaker so God gave us Trump God said
I need somebody willing to get up before
Dawn fix this country work all day fight
the Marxist eat supper then go to the
Oval Office and stay past midnight at a
meeting of the heads of state so God
made Trump I need somebody with arms
strong enough to rustle the Deep State
and yet gentle enough to to deliver his
own grandchild somebody to ruffle the
feathers tame cantankerous World
economic Forum come home hungry have to
wait until the first lady is done with
lunch with friends then tell the ladies
to be sure and come back real soon and
mean it so God gave us Trump I need
somebody who can shape an axe but wield
a sword who had the courage to step foot
in North Korea who can make money from
the tar of the sand turn liquid to Gold
who understands the difference between
tariffs and inflation will finish his
40-hour week by Tuesday noon but then
put in another 72 hours so God made
Trump God had to have somebody willing
to go into the den of vipers call out
the fake news for their tongues as sharp
as a serpents the poison of vipers is on
their lips and yet stop so God made
Trump God said I need somebody who will
be strong and courageous who will not be
afraid or terrified of the Wolves when
they attack a man who cares for the
flock a Shepherd to mankind who won't
ever leave nor forsake them I need the
most diligent worker to follow the path
and remain strong in faith and know the
belief of God and Country somebody who's
willing to drill bring back
manufacturing and American jobs Farm the
lands secure our borders build our
military fight the system all day and
finish a hard week's work by attending
church on Sunday and then his oldest son
turns and says Dad let's make America
great again Dad let's build back a
country to be the Envy of the world
again there's your there's your
Theocratic
monarchy don't tell me this [__]
election's going to be about
immigration don't tell me this [__]
this election is going to be about the
border and if you're saying that [__]
out loud if you're saying that [__] out
loud you're a dumb [__] you're a
dumb
[__] and I'll say it to your
[__] face too don't think I
won't this is not going to be about
[__] immigration this election is not
going to be about the
Border
democracy versus
autocracy will democracy
win or will they we allow them to use it
to kill our constitutional Democratic
Republic and turn it into the
Theocratic fascist monarchy that they so
desire for and they fap
to they're jerking off to this
[__] it's sick it's twisted and we can
[__] beat it because there's way
[__] more of us than there are of
them way [__] many more people who
[__] hear this [__] about having some
[__] monarchy and God made Trump and
God's going to put him in charge of us
and make him our [__] King because
Jesus said
so
unamerican fundamentally 100%
unquestionably
unamerican
foundationally it is is not patriotic it
is against our founding principles of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and I will not stop yelling
and
screaming and pushing the narrative and
cascading The Narrative out to make sure
that the messaging in this country saves
our democracy and people engage in our
democracy and do what democracy do best
send fascism p
just like we will tomorrow same time
same place Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist Miss and
repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
Tony I just want to say dictators don't
become billionaires overnight
okay country time for a Theocratic
monarchy King Trump for life let's go
hey I think if we had a monarchy there'
be a lot less corruption because you
can't be bought you know you don't have
to be bought because you're always in
control you don't have to be paid for
with campaign cash because you're always
G to be in control and you're going to
pass it on to your children and that
kind of thing especially if they do
Bloodlines but very interesting stuff
just just a suggestion doesn't sound too
terrible it's worked uh throughout the
majority of history and uh King Jesus
remember our Lord believes in uh the
Theocratic uh the monarchal structure